la fnac
mais oui
mais oui c'est vous ça y est vous êtes
de retour
venez avec moi je lis ailleurs ischia ça
ils sont venus tous les enfants sont
arrivés regarde là bas mais c'est vrai
c'est merveilleux eh bien vous savez
vous nous avez manqué bienvenue à tous
dans l'île aux enfants
j'espère que vous avez passé de bonnes
vacances et nous ici c'est qu'elle est
très calme oui un peu trop calme m
bonjour mes amis bonjour bonjour acteur
beau temps aujourd'hui pour les uns mais
dites vous bien ça y est ils sont
revenus
oui et oui bonjour a tous dit ça fait
plaisir de les retrouver et aura pour
sûr dites moi et à propos de casimir
vous n'avez pas de nouvelles août aucune
non c'est une disparition bien
inquiétante deux mois et demi sans signe
de vie
pour sûr il est parti en vacances ça oui
sans doute sans doute nous enfin ce
n'explique pas tout il aurait pu envoyer
une carte postale
mes chers amis j'ai l'insigne honneur de
vous saluer et auquel bonne surprise je
me suis dit non
mam s'est dit stop vous avez passé de
bonnes vacances trentenaire votre
charabia
j'ai été reçue fait des gens de très
grande qualité avec qui nous avons parlé
de philosophie psychologie métaphysique
pas ta fille cela devait être passionné
très enrichissant tonsure par rennes
jérémy il l'a fait plaisir de retrouver
un jugement aussi directe que le vôtre
après des journées entières passées à
discuter mais je n'ai pas encore vu ce
gros balourd de casimir
je n'ai pas un gros ballon enfin casimir
souvent des réactions assez inattendu
c'est vrai mais elle est quand même très
intelligente pour sûr
j'avoue même que parfois il dit les
choses que je ne comprends pas très bien
mes chers amis n'en jetez plus je
plaisantais bon et cela fait plaisir de
voir avec quelle ardeur vous défendez
vos amis un à cela est une noble et
belles aptitudes et vous savez que c'est
j'aime à le taquiner parfois j'éprouve
beaucoup de sympathie pour qu'elles s'y
mirent c'est vrai ça vous n'avez pas
répondu
où est il je les fautes accord salué
pour tout vous dire monsieur de ce noble
nous sommes assez inquiets vous savez
qu'il est parti en vacances il y a deux
mois et demi je saison dire où ils
allaient et depuis nous sommes sans
nouvelles pas la moindre petite carte
postale
et pourtant monsieur du snop j'ai
vérifié le courrier tous les jours mes
chers amis cela m'inquiète beaucoup
garges même beaucoup voyagé j'ai vu
beaucoup de pays et je n'ai jamais
entendu parler de son passage pendant
les vacances
bonjour
lui quasi effet comment expliques tu
nous appelles tu peux penser à ses amies
en région je suis très content de vous
retrouver tous et j'ai apporté mon
souvenir de vacances
de quoi s'agit-il états unis où étais-tu
en vacances ah mais vous êtes trop
curieux voilà il va falloir deviner ce
sera notre premier jeu de la saison
l'excellente idée préfériez pas que je
vous parle de mes discussions
métaphysique que huit heures plus tard
ah bon et bien si cela commence comme ça
préfère me retirer tout de suite un bon
j'ai travaux urgents qui m'attendent à
bientôt mais sur scène on voit les
enfants les enfants mais voir on va
terrain jeu et vous si chez vous et vous
allez essayer de trouver enfin ce qui se
passe casimir va nous raconter ses
vacances il va falloir trouver où il est
allé et ceux qui nous ont rapporté comme
souvenir entendu à toi casini intègre et
bien j'ai été d'abord dans un endroit
très chaud il y avait du sable très doux
et des coquillages et des petits
poissons de toutes les couleurs qui
nageait dans une eau très clair alors à
votre avis les enfants ou était quasi
mercedes dit haïti alors tahiti c'est ou
mercedes c'est autour d'eux c'était ça
que ça doit être ça ou la même mais il y
avait également des étendues blanches
groupe
il faisait très froid et même les
sapeurs était tout blanc alors il votre
avis
oui si à la neige aussi ça pourrait
peut-être en russie c'était très haut je
crois très très haut non en montagne a
très bien
ah oui ça pourrait être ça qu'on soit en
effet fruits il y avait également des
prairies et klein d'animaux d'élevage
des chevaux des chèvres des moutons et
des petits lapins partout à votre lit en
normandie
casimir sait où pour être servi oui mais
on y trouve tout dit dans wave mais
écoutez ce n'est pas tout un
il y avait également des des rivières de
la grenadine les arbres dont les fruits
étaient dé glace à la fraise ou bien est
il y avait des panthères qui jouaient
aux dominos avec des lapins bleus rien
je n'ai jamais rien entendu semble des
enfants comme aux cheveux fléchissez ou
et texte toutes ces choses très très
bizarre ou savourer ce passé ce que ça
pourrait vraiment se passer
alors moi j'ai une petite idée ne l'est
pas on va voir car me remets mais
attendez ce n'est pas tout parfois
j'étais dans tous ces endroits à la fois
oui alors est-ce que vous avez prouvé
qu'elle est l'objet souvenir de mes
vacances que je vous ai apporté tous les
endroits en même temps vous avez deviné
bien je crois je crois casimir que nous
donnons notre langue au chat
oui si on a un objet trop mystérieux
mystérieux et c'est pas mystérieux du
tout regardé le mot
c'est un an eye est consciente que
j'aurais jamais trouvé mais enfin vous
ne vous souvenez pas que nous autres les
casimir us nous sommes comme les
marmottes ou plutôt le contraire des
marmottes
nous dormons tout l'été alors j'ai passé
des vacances formidables avec mon beau
petit oreiller bien moelleux
j'ai fait des rêves merveilleux
[Musique]
avec une chanson d'imagination j'avoue
sans remède d'entreprise du bonheur
[Musique]
zoomer ou pays
je sois y est terrorisée je suis le
monstre qui périt
map est quasi me
la bombe
[Musique]
aussi dit que non
si l'on me dit maladroit mois
je sais jouer de la musique
je suis né ce martin camirand
et me la glace aux anchois c'est
pourquoi c'est mon droit avec deux
chansons
un peu d'imagination
vous emmène dans notre île du bonheur
tranquille
ces couleurs incompris ne soyez pas
terrorisé je suis le monstre qui fait
rire
ap le cassis
j'ai une machine elle une idée
fantastique je mange
gloubi boulga mais jeune femme à la
compagnie j'ai vu la ville de caen can
you see mais mike a eu droit c'est mon
droit hongrois est une chanson
imagination
[Musique]
dans notre ici jeu
icon r
francky
il faut faire
2 soyez
je suis le bon ce qui fait rire
m'appelle quasi mythe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]